okay let's take another question rachel
what's a unique insight about food and
or robotics you learned from your
investment in cafe x oh wow learned a
lot okay
let's talk about hardware when you're
building a hardware company whether it's
density which does people counting or
cafe x or we had a smoke detector
company
and
we had a
webcam company like a drop cam
competitor
in all four of those cases i learned
that hardware is hard because when you
make a hardware company you have to buy
10 000 units you have to fabricate them
you have to ship them all of that
and you have to get people to pay for
the hardware
and then you still have to build all the
software so a software company builds
software
and a hardware company builds software
and hardware plus they have to
distribute them now you look at cafe x
they have to build the hardware they got
to build the software
they also have to manage locations and
they have to manage the maintenance of
those machines in other words the
consumer facing stuff so when they did
their locations it was great it was
working
fantastic
but you basically are running three
startups a retail operation a hardware
operation and a software operation
that's hard
so you're basically running sweet greens
you're running fitbit or apple watches
and you're running a software company
like slack
sounds hard right it is and then uh
eventually where
cafex wound up was
you know the airport locations were
fantastic
one hour of maintenance and they had to
get through a lot of local regulations
like one county might be fine with milk
being in a vending machine another
county you might say no milk and vending
machines because
there were you know health concerns
about it well
in the in a modern
robotic one you don't have to worry
about milk fresh milk being in it it's
refrigerated we have sensors but in an
old coffee machine you could only do
powdered right
so there were some antiquated
regulations you had that to it turns out
they
rushed it inside of sfo
i wouldn't say the numbers it's up to
henry to share them but that is a really
good business
but operating is hard so they've moved
to hey if you want to buy the machine
for i think 250k and then pay a
maintenance fee or a service fee of 2000
a month you can buy the machines and put
them anywhere you want and now they've
had a half dozen people do that so they
took out
we're going to be the retail operator
you go
put them in we'll sell them to you
hardware as a service hass
you know sas this is hass hardware as a
service density did the same thing
density makes sensors that will tell you
how many people are in a restaurant or
cafe
what they realized was
um
the hardware business stinks and those
customers let's say cafes
do they really get a ton of value from
this not as much value as an enterprise
company so imagine you're
some giant company with a campus like
nyu or stanford
or your microsoft or google or facebook
or linkedin somebody who's got a giant
campus now you've got a million square
feet hundreds of thousands of square
feet you don't know how your space is
being used you know how people in
planning figure that out they send
somebody out there with a clipper and
they count people they set up a webcam
and they count everybody on the webcam
now imagine if i could show you in real
time and you play a button and you see
the floor plan
of the 50th floor the 49th floor on the
48th floor of your most expensive office
space in manhattan looking out of
central park and you can see the
capacity of all the spaces and how
utilized the spaces are
and now you find out your boardroom is
being used
by one person on average or 1.2 people
you're like well that's a 12 person
board room that's costing us
400 dollars a year
and it's being used as a phone booth so
then you get three phone booths and you
find out that they're used eighty
percent of the time
and those are costing you
fifteen thousand dollars a year each oh
my god what a better use of space and
then you know the legal department is
saying we need this much space and the
sales department's saying we need this
space
but the it department
is like actually using their space and
the lawyers and the sales people are
never there
so now you can have the operations
people because of density
are able to say you know what
and it's density.io
uh we have hardware that we pay for
that is not cameras so it doesn't invade
anybody's privacy and we know exactly
the utilization of the entire space so
we're going to consolidate the new york
operation from three floors down to two
we're gonna put six more phone booths in
because those are what we need and we're
gonna take that 12 person board room
that ever gets used and we're gonna put
two dividers in it and we're gonna make
it into three four person breakout rooms
and if people need to we'll take the
dividers out for the three times a year
we have a board meeting in that
boardroom brilliant stuff like that
uh and if you pay for it as a service
just a monthly fee and you abstract the
hardware cost into that it makes it much
more accessible and you're now you found
your ideal customer profile so that's
what hardware companies really have to
do they have to figure out a way to turn
it into a subscription and it's really
interesting as a business
you have to get out of certain
businesses and find your ideal customer
profile so if opening up a bunch of
locations in san francisco and they get
vandalized it's a terrible idea
but you know having airports uh or
campuses is a great idea awesome so you
know to the founders of cafe x henry and
density in their teams
my lord you have my respect because
hardware is hard but if you do figure it
out hardware plus software in a in a
subscription package
it's super powerful i think it's super
powerful and i think actually
a density's had massive success
obviously
henry and cafex took a bad beat
because of the pandemic but coming out
of the pandemic
there's no workers and nobody wants to
be a barista and people want 24-hour
service and maybe people don't want
people touching their food as much or as
much contact with other humans
contactless is now something that
consumers want and let's face it people
don't want to work in those jobs so the
idea when cafex came out was like oh my
god you're taking away barista jobs and
now it's like nobody wants those jobs we
all admit nobody wants those jobs nobody
wants to be a driver anymore so
self-driving
uh nobody wants to work in a fields you
know picking strawberries so rude ai is
picking strawberries with robots i think
we're gonna see the robots
and hardware play a bigger role and the
robots are leaving the factories and
that really is the trend in the bet we
made on cafe x was robots have changed
how factories work
now what happens when the robots leave
the factory that was my basic premise
and i looked at everything the
dishwashing bot the french fry one
they're all out there and i think post
pandemic with this
crisis of we're not letting
immigrants into the country who would
take these jobs so we're anti-immigrant
and we got 10 million jobs and americans
don't want to take those jobs and those
jobs
you know if they cost 35 an hour 25 an
hour for a dishwasher which is what they
were getting paid in san francisco i
know that sounds crazy people always
email me and when i tell them when
people get paid in san francisco like
that's crazy i'm like
now try buying a house in san francisco
you really get the definition of crazy
yeah people somebody i know is paying 35
an hour for a dishwasher in san
francisco if you're paying 35 an hour
it's a 10 hour shift it's 350
and you've got you know two shifts a day
700 a day
and you're open 300 days a year you
start to figure out you're spending
hundreds of thousands a year on the
dishwasher function at your restaurant
yeah you might switch to a robot you
might right you might start thinking you
know what okay now it's time to do a
robot
when you can get people to work for 10
bucks an hour as a dishwasher or to make
french fries you don't think about it
you're like i can get people people need
the jobs i'll just hire people for 10
bucks an hour and so that's a little bit
more than yes for but
i think it's going to be very
interesting when the robots leave the
factories and it's gonna be great for
society because
humans always find other work and so the
idea that humans are not gonna create
more jobs is silly like we're gonna
always create more jobs there are
there's the creator economy people are
getting paid to make podcasts that are
super niche they're getting paid
to tweet they're getting paid to write
email newsletters on any number of
subjects patreon you just look at the
world of creativity on youtube and
people making a living there
which people are getting like we're
talking about tens of thousands of
people on twitch are getting paid to
play video games
if i told you to you know if you told me
in the 80s imagine getting paid to play
video games i would have been like a
video game tester like i actually
thought about that as a career the two
jobs i really wanted when i was in my
teens
i wanted to be roger e but i wanted to
get paid
to watch movies and then write about
them because i just something clicked to
me and said wait a second i love going
to the movies
and that guy's getting paid it was like
one of my earliest observations in
entrepreneurship was that siskel and
ebert were getting paid to watch movies
and i loved going to movies and i was
paying to watch them it was like when
that lit up in my brain i was like whoa
and then somebody told me about video
game testing and i was like wait a
second
you go to work and play video games i'm
going to work and then going home to
play video games i'd like to have that
job